Let's look at the solution for our control dependence
quiz in a pipeline. We know how many instructions
are taken branches. We don't really care that it's
a ten stage pipeline. What we care about is that
the branches are resolved in the sixth stage and
that everything else works smoothly. So the actual CPI will
be one per instruction. This happens for branches and
all the other instructions. Plus for every taken branch, and
that happens 25% of the instructions, we have
a penalty of five cycles. Why? Because when
we resolve the branch in the sixth stage.
They have already been five stages worth of
instructions. That we fetched from the wrong place
and we have to throw them away. So
following a branch like this there will be
five cycles in which we don't finish anything,
so we spend one cycle per instruction and
for 25% of instructions. We spend additional five
cycles for that instruction. Basically there are five
empty cycles after it. If you multiply this
out you get 2.25. As you can see, this CPI is very far from the ideal. Our
processor is less than half as fast as it would be without the taken branches.